building bridges between tomorrow and
today
between science and art with its
transdisciplinary exhibition hypotopia
berlin-based state studio offers a new
thought-provoking approach
how could a post-crisis future look like
and what does this mean for the present
moment
we meet the curator christian roch in
his exhibition hall where he explains
the concept
in more detail hypotopia
explores through artistic positions and
scientific explorations the
post-crisis future where we have
managed to find a different way of how
to interact
with our global surrounding with
species that we cohabit our planet with
and
by showing artistic positions that
act as pockets of hope we want to
inspire through this exhibition a
different
way of engaging with our environment
we are featuring
10 artists in seven artworks
hypertopia is more than just an
exhibition it is a program
which wants to inspire discussions and
encourage people to exchange ideas
with one another field trips to exciting
urban spaces in berlin
and digital events are also offered
it is also worth mentioning that we do
not
try to propose hypotopia as a unique
concept and a unique curatorial concept
on its own
much rather we try to interlink our
exhibition with many other artistic and
scientific initiatives that are out
there already that deal very much with
the same
question of systemic change and propose
new modes of understanding with an
artistic approach
the project wants to encourage people to
think about their relation to nature
and their preservation
the biggest question that we are
dealing with with this exhibition is one
of the biggest questions of our time
it's the question of our relationship
with these planets
and its myriad life forms
that inhabited and
how we need to change and how we need to
change our actions
in order to find a sustainable way that
will allow positive and
and hopeful future not only for us but
also
for for the many other life forms
the project wants to challenge
hierarchies examine new ideas and
inspire people to think about
new optimism in society not only locally
but globally there are ways that
we can contribute to a change in this
world
opening a space for people to come
together artists
and scientists and people from the
general public
that are all interested and concerned
alike with
what our future might bring and how we
need to need to adapt and change our
ways of dealing with our surroundings
and ask questions we don't really have
answers to all of this
as a species yet of how we need to go
forward in order to
to find ways for for a sustainable
future
but it's only through coming together
it's only through collectiveness it's
only through
it's changing with each other and
bringing different viewpoints on
into one space such as for example
specific
exhibition and finding formats for
people to interact with each other
that we can find such answers